quick who's the first presidential
candidate you think of this year yep
we're talking about him hello Internet
welcome to film theory now fortified
with a hundred fifty percent of your
daily dose of knowledge now producing
this show forces me to say pretty darn
up-to-date with my TV viewing it takes
me to all sorts of programming from
killing zombies to Rose ceremonies to
yelling at people who have no idea how
bidding works come on people when you're
the last person to bid on The Price is
Right what dollar is the best option
it's called playing the odds
so lately there's been something
interrupting my nightly dose of Modern
Family the election but not just the
election one man in particular Donald
Trump mr. Trump Donald Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump is
everywhere and sure when you're on the
short list of people who could be the
next president of the United States you
should plan to get some media exposure
but it seems like every election story
has been about him he's just one
candidate out of about 300 who entered
for someone who's never held public
office before he's doing really well his
candidacy started as a punchline in are
you kidding me moment in an age of
shameless publicity stunts but as of the
writing of this episode he just won the
New Hampshire primaries which is good
since I've been working on this episode
for a while now and if he suddenly
tagged all this work would have been
wasted but this whole time I keep asking
myself how I mean don't get me wrong I
like The Apprentice as much as the next
guy but why would people want a real
estate tycoon to be President how does
someone with no experience dominate a
race full of veteran politicians
I mean before this past year the thing
that most interested the public about
this guy was his hair seriously is that
a toupee or not so I've been following
what Trump has been doing and I was
surprised by what I found Trump's
campaign tactics are unusual but I've
seen him before
not from politicians but from reality TV
testing Donald Trump knows how TV works
especially reality TV and he knows what
kind of players are the most likely to
survive to the end and after today's
episode you will too so if you want to
become the next frontrunner for your
nation's elected leader stay tuned
because I'll show you how in four easy
steps with the help of our good friend
the Don now this comparison of an
election to reality TV might seem absurd
at first but think about it both their
contests with a cast of characters who
have cameras rolling on them all the
time just like the channel II and shows
like Entertainment Tonight cover the
latest news about the Kardashians
channels like CNN and shows like the
nightly news cover the election it's all
news and it's all entertainment just
with various degrees of substance most
of the time Trump is the one who seems
to be most aware of the camera one who
wants this race to be as much a
spectacle as it is a political
discussion and The Washington Post says
he uses Twitter far more prolifically
than the other candidates so he's
clearly playing the game in a more
modern media savvy fashion than his
opponents in the first several months of
his campaign that reality TV style of
self-promotion and gamesmanship has been
translating to voter support and so my
fellow humanoids here's the reality show
blueprint that Trump has been using as
his ultimate trump cards that pun was
pretty ham handed step 1 create a clear
persona reality shows have big cast and
a limited time to introduce viewers to
them so the simpler and more memorable
someone's persona is the better
pop-culture philosopher Chuck Klosterman
notes in his book sex drugs and Cocoa
Puffs that reality shows like the real
world the granddaddy of reality TV put a
lot of effort into boiling down their
participants into oversimplified
archetypes like the guy who plays the
race card or naive southern girl think
about some of reality TV's most iconic
moments and characters Jonny Fairplay
from Survivor who lied about his
grandmother's death to stay an extra
week on the show
my grandmother's sitting home watching
Jerry Springer right now villain puck
from the real world who wore a Nazi
swastika shirt and refused to remove it
when he was asked to by his Jewish
housemate villain Omarosa from season 1
of The Apprentice who wrong
he claimed that other contestants were
racist I called her a baby I told her to
go in the corner and get her pacifier
and her blanket and go cry which is what
she always does villain huh it's funny
how many of the first examples to come
to mind are villains interesting but if
you really want evidence of this trend
look no further than shows like The
Amazing Race we're all teams compact
with a one-line identifier dating
newlyweds LGBT youtubers wait Tyler
Tyler what are you doing on there and
burn it Bert Burnie burns well fine I
see that neither of you wanted to be my
partner that's okay my feelings aren't
hurt or anything
mmm in all seriousness though recent
seasons of Survivor have stopped trying
to hide it all together heroes vs.
villains brains versus brawn versus
beauty it's like high school all over
again
jock nerd girl with loose morals we as
humans just like to classify it's more
efficient if I say man that guy is such
a jock you already know a lot about him
without me having to explain his whole
life history and if you're picking one
candidate in this year's presidential
race who doesn't care about getting
along with other people and fits into a
few simple categories Donald Trump
whether you pay attention to politics or
not you know what kind of qualities
Trump is using to identify himself with
he's a businessman not a politician he's
rich he's famous he's successful and
he's not afraid to say whatever pops
into his head depending on your
perspective he's either a bully or a
no-nonsense outsider but either way
Trump has labeled himself better than
any other Republican in the race other
candidates are more experienced be sure
but can you put Marco Rubio or Ted Cruz
into a box that easily No and that makes
them a lot harder to follow because it
requires more effort to know who they
are and what they stand for at this
point everyone knows who Donald Trump is
and what he stands for he has the
clearest persona step to stick to a
message when you're filming a reality
show you get a lot of footage the
Biggest Loser for instance has 11
cameras running for eight hours a day
seven days a week
that's 616 hours of footage to make a
single 42 minute long episode so if you
have something to say you better make it
simple and you better make it quick the
number one slot of pretty much any
greatest reality TV moments of all time
list tends to go to the infamous snake
rat speech from the final episode of
season 1 of Survivor this was an
electric moment of television in it
truck driver sue Hawk delivers a
scathing speech to her former alliance
mates acquainting 1/2 a snake and 1/2 a
rat but if I were ever pass you along in
life again and you were laying there
dying of thirst I would not give you a
drink of water and encouraging the
voters to follow the course of nature
and let the snake eat the rat it's so
memorable because it's so simple and
direct and honest and as a result its
endured for decades since it was first
uttered or if you want an even better
example of sticking to a message look no
further than dr. Wilker B from Big
Brother never before has a clearer case
of sociopathy been put to film as this
man the self-proclaimed puppet master
gonna look like flesh on the outside rip
it open
it's just circuitry and wires but what
makes him so special in the second
season he repeatedly told everyone to
their face that he would lie to and
betray them on the show and he did week
after week his teammates would get
backstabbed and yet they continued to
trust him until he eventually won the
whole show he won the ship oh when I say
that he stuck to his message he really
stuck to his message when he returned in
the all-star season he did it all again
literally telling everyone in the house
in the first few weeks how much he hated
them so I had a heart-to-heart with
myself and I said will what is the
reason why are you having such a hard
time playing and this is the truth I
can't find an individual to hate because
I hate you all and then went on to make
the final four and ensure that his best
friend would take home the grand prize
but it may well be that Donald Trump
learned to simplify his message from one
of the contestants on his very own show
the breakout star Omarosa lover hater or
love D hater
Omarosa always stay direct and on
message including when she coined what
has become one of the most famous
mantras in reality TV I didn't come here
to make friends
I said that from day one Omarosa wasn't
secretive about doing whatever it would
take to win and she won a lot of fans
over with that level of honesty suffice
it to say that Donald Trump is probably
not running for president to make
friends just like amorosa he's trying to
win in case there's any doubt he talks
about winning constantly winning we have
to win an Iowa I'm gonna win I think I'm
gonna win Iowa man that guy twos his own
horn a lot you might say that he's
trumpeting his success trumpeting all
right all right that was the last Trump
pun I swear when it comes to Trump's
message he keeps it simple and punchy in
fact his message is so simple it's
comprised of words kids could see on
Sesame Street
tough win great one syllable at a time
it doesn't get much easier than that pen
reminds you of Pope and change a couple
years ago huh and these are it is for
people to understand your message the
easier it is for them to get behind you
step three bring the drama let's face it
our favorite reality TV personalities
aren't always the most mentally or
emotionally stable but those kinds of
people are also the producers favorites
because you never know what they're
gonna do next
and that makes for exciting television
we've already talked about a lot of
other examples but the one I'd like to
focus on here is from one of America's
finest artistic achievements RuPaul's
Drag Race if you're unfamiliar with the
show RuPaul's Drag Race has nothing to
do with souped-up cars
it features drag queens competing in
competitions ranging from fashion to
stand-up comedy to lip-syncing and yeah
you can bet there's plenty of drama to
go around a lot of talking you [ __ ]
everybody's BFF and kicky kicky kicky
game no this is not RuPaul's best friend
race Sherlock the best came in season
four of drag race which featured Chad
Michaels a dead ringer cher impersonator
I'm cher bear
Sharon Needles who is equal parts punk
rock and comedy and Latrice Royale get
those nuts away from my face
but in a field of talented funny drag
queens it felt like one in particular
Fifi O'Hara was dominating all the
airtime how I bring the heat to anyone
and everyone everyone hated her she was
the worst I hated watching her it was
awful but at the same time I couldn't
look away at least I am a showgirl [ __ ]
go back to party city where you belong
similarly nobody on the campaign trail
this past year has had or created more
bees than Donald Trump he started so
many places surprised that Vince McMahon
hasn't hired him on to be a professional
wrestler actually got a truck
the list of people Trump's Bosch is
lengthy
Fox News reporters fellow Republicans
like Ted Cruz and Jeb Bush and of course
Hillary Clinton combined this with Trump
calling Mexicans rapists and proposing a
ban on allowing Muslims to enter the
country and Trump has been all over the
news cycle since the moment he declared
his candidacy they say that any
publicity is good publicity and Trump is
definitely winning that game according
to the Washington Post from June through
November Donald Trump had more airtime
on the news than the entire Democratic
field combined and about a quarter of
all news time total in spite of the fact
that he had to split that time with
twenty other candidates with that amount
of free advertising it would be more
surprising if Trump weren't in the lead
I mean look it must be effective you
don't see me making film theories about
other candidates
Touche Donald Touche and finally step 4
stay one step ahead of your opponents in
reality competition shows the best
players are the ones who can read their
opponents and disguise their strategy
let's take a look at the player host
Jeff Probst called the best player in
the history of Survivor Russell Hantz
never before has there been a clear
example of sociopathy put to film as
this man and that's including dr. will
Russell played the game three times he
was a finalist twice and the one time he
wasn't a finalist his own team lost on
purpose because they were so scared of
him
we'll put Russell and everyone's
watchlist was that he broke the game
circumventing rules that everyone had
just assumed were in place specifically
he found the hidden immunity idols the
item that protects people come voting
time before having any clues about where
it was or the show telling them it was a
thing that existed again she's found
this second hidden immunity idol without
a clue if you convinced a player on the
other team to give him an immunity idol
on a season in which the show itself
labeled Russell as a villain you don't
hand the enemy the eye
especially when his name is Russell
hands he don't do that he even resorted
to psychological warfare against his own
team by pouring out their water and
burning their socks in an attempt to
break their spirits as Russell put it
himself if I can control how they feel I
can control how they think this man he
is like a hero to me in only the way
that like a super villain can be like
someone that you admire you know anyway
now look at Trump Trump's opponents
spent most of January drumming off as
much support in Iowa as possible Ted
Cruz and Marco Rubio each held twice as
many events as Trump did but Trump
played a wild card with a surprise
endorsement from Sarah Palin Palin's
speech was mocked by a lot of people but
Trump was able to stay in the limelight
ahead of his competitors through one
single event and remember this wasn't
just any endorsement this is Sarah Palin
a political figure who is very divisive
someone who the sheer mention of her
name drums up emotion with most voters
and that gets attention who cares about
a bunch of stuffy events here's a news
story I can really get headlines with
and then two days before January's final
debate Trump just decided to hold his
own rally instead of attending it's like
Russell he's breaking the game
challenging rules that everyone just
assumed were in place
I mean who skips debates it's unheard of
this made headlines in its own right but
now think about his opponents Trump had
spent so much time criticizing and
insulting the people on that stage you
know that they were prepared to go on
the offensive but at the last minute he
pulls the rug out from under them and
doesn't show putting them off their
balance and forcing them to rethink
their approach while it worked who are
they gonna attack now the Washington
Post notes the candidates switched more
of their attacks to Ted Cruz in Trump's
absence throughout his whole campaign
Donald Trump has differentiated himself
by not following the beaten path and in
doing so has tried to control how his
opponents feel when he attacks them
because like Russell if he can control
how they feel he can predict how they'll
think and more importantly how they'll
react so congratulations you now know
the four steps to being a front-runner
in your presidential campaign but here's
the thing Donald Trump has a lot of
things going for him he has the clearest
persona for everyone to understand
his messages simple and is able to
dominate the conversation he brings
enough drama to keep voters attention
and he can even predict and undermine
the moves his opponents are about to
make so obviously he has to be a lot to
be the Republican nominee writes well
not necessarily because while all these
steps are critical to making reality TV
stars they don't necessarily create
reality TV winners Omarosa fifi O'Hara
and Russell Hantz got relatively famous
but they all lost Huck was the most
famous person on the real world San
Francisco but he was evicted from the
house midway through the season because
everyone hated him and this isn't even a
show where evictions are a thing that
exists they're just supposed to live
together you're not voting people out of
everyone that we talked about dr. will
is the only winner and that's because
man this guy is charming he is so awful
but he is so so charming do you think
it's easy being this good-looking it is
easy
in short Donald Trump is like a survivor
contestant who emerges as an early
leader he's gathered support gotten a
lot of airtime but now his tribe is
trying to bring him down before it's too
late
in this case the tribe is the Republican
establishment and the endorsements made
by Republican governors and members of
Congress are like votes in the Tribal
Council the endorsements in favor of Ted
Cruz Marco Rubio and Jeb Bush continued
to climb while endorsements for Donald
Trump are few and far between Republican
leaders worry that this guy's an
embarrassment that they won't be able to
get Trump to compromise that he's not
the kind of guy who will sit down to
dinner and meet you halfway like some
sort of lady in the Trump sari honest
talk I have a serious pun problem need
like some sort of pun addicts anonymous
hello my name is Matthew Patrick and I'm
a pawn addict anyhow the Donald is
starting to feel the effects of the
Republican establishments backlash after
leading the polls for most of the few
months leading up to the Iowa caucus he
finished second receiving well below the
percentage of the vote he was projected
to get Trump's not done fighting yet
like I said he won the New Hampshire
primary but there's definitely blood in
the water
if the parallels between Trump and our
reality stars are any indication he
might be able to outwit his opponents
and debates and outplay them in the
media game but he probably won't outlast
them but hey that's just a theory a film
theory
and cuts mr. Trump quick question what
would you say to someone who thinks
you're acting more like a reality TV
star than a presidential candidate you
fired
ah